Die Horror-Meldungen in vielen Medien überschlagen
sich: Die Rede ist von einem neuen “Dürre-Sommer”,
“Sahara-Sommer” und einem neuen “Hitzerekord”
im Jahr 2019.
Das weckt unschöne Erinnerungen an das vergangene
Jahr, das laut dem Deutschen Wetterdienst
“DWD) das viert-trockendste Jahr in Deutschland
seit 1881 war.
Willkommen bei Clixom Science & Fiction Hier
gibt es täglich faszinierende Science-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Es waren ja nicht nur die massiven Ernteausfälle,
die sich nach Schätzungen des Deutschen Bauernverbandes
auf eine Höhe von bis zu drei Milliarden
Euro beliefen.
Die extreme Trockenheit im Jahr 2018 machte
auch anderen Wirtschaftszweigen zu schaffen.
Die großen Flüsse in den betroffenen Gebieten
führten deutlich weniger Wasser als sonst,
sodass der Warenverkehr nur noch eingeschränkt
oder gar nicht mehr möglich war.
So der Fall beispielsweise zwischen Dresden
und Magdeburg.
Zudem starben deutschlandweit Pflanzen ab
und Brände haben mehrere hundert Hektar Wald
zerstört - unter anderem im Naturschutzgebiet
Lieberoser Heide.
Schnell wurden Vergleiche mit 2003 laut: Ein
extrem trockenes Jahr mit einer gewaltigen
Hitzewelle und Temperaturen bis zu rund 47
Grad.
Eine der größten Naturkatastrophen, die
der Kontinent je gesehen hat.
Flüsse waren ausgetrocknet, Wälder abgebrannt
und zehntausende Menschen starben damals.
Es traf vor allem ältere Leute, denn Klimaanlagen
versagten und die Krankenhäuser waren überfüllt
mit Hitzeopfern.
Letztendlich steht fest: Im Vergleich dazu
sind wir dem Hitzesommer 2018 noch gut davongekommen.
Allerdings: das war der erste Sommer, bei
dem Klimaexperten gesagt haben: Das ist konkret
eine Folge des Kimawandels.
Denn das gab es noch nie: Die gesamte Nordhalbkugel
war überdurchschnittlich warm.
Beängstigend.
Und es gibt Spätfolgen und so ist das Jahr
2019 unter extrem schlechten Vorboten gestartet.
Der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt Ende April
(2019): “In vielen Regionen Deutschlands
sind 2019 zum Start der Vegetationsperiode
die Böden viel trockener als im vieljährigen
Durchschnitt.
Zum Vergleich: Selbst im Dürrejahr 2018 lagen
nach Berechnungen des Deutschen Wetterdienstes
(DWD) die Boden-Feuchtwerte im April deutlich
über den aktuellen Werten dieses Jahres.
Demnach müssen wir uns auf den nächsten
Dürresommer gefasst machen, WENN die trockene
Witterung auch in den kommenden Monaten weiter
anhält.
Dieser könnte Prognosen zufolge sogar noch
ein drastischere Folgen haben als die Trockenheit
im Jahr 2018.
Nicht nur Ertragseinbußen in der Landwirtschaft
drohen dann.
Auch Wälder und Pflanzen, die eher tiefere
Bodenschichten anzapfen, um an Feuchtigkeit
zu gelangen, könnten dann betroffen sein.
Denn auch diese Speicher sind laut DWD deutlich
weniger gut gefüllt als im Vorjahr.
Denn das sehr extreme Niederschlagsdefizit
aus 2018 konnte auch durch den Niederschlag,
der von Dezember 2018 bis März 2019 gefallen
ist, nicht kompensiert werden.
Dazu Udo Busch vom Deutschen Wetterdienst:
“Die Startbedingungen für die Vegetation
sind 2019 in vielen Gebieten Deutschlands
deutlich schlechter als im Vorjahr”.
Mögliche Ernte-Verluste könnten die aus
dem vergangenen Jahr massiv übertreffen,
befürchtet auch der Agrarwissenschaftler
Peter Gerand aus Göttingen.
Er hat bei Messungen festgestellt, dass die
Böden Jahre brauchen werden, um sich zu erholen.
Der Forscher fasst zusammen: “Die Situation
ist an vielen Standorten sehr sehr angespannt.
Die Niederschläge des Winters reichen mancherorts
gerade mal aus, um die obersten 20 Zentimeter
mit Feuchtigkeit aufzuschwemmen".
Besonders betroffen ist der sowieso schon
trockene Osten Deutschlands – vor allem
Sachsen-Anhalt und Thüringen.
Teilweise fehle als Folge des extremen Sommers
im Jahr 2018 in den Böden pro Quadratmeter
200 bis 300 Liter Wasser.
Und nicht nur Deutschland hat dieses Problem
mit übertrockenen Böden.
Auch in Ost- und Nordeuropa lag die Bodenfeuchtigkeit
im April unter dem Durchschnitt.
Und so könnte auch hier eine neue Dürre
drohen.
Und die Pflanzen leiden nicht nur unter dem
Wassermangel; auch der Transport von Nährstoffen
aus dem Boden verringert sich.
Die Nährstoffe aus dem Dünger verbleiben
also im Boden.
Regnet es, kommt es zu höheren Nitratgehalten
im Grundwasser.
Und selbst das ist nicht alles; auch die Wälder
könnten hart von einer weiteren Dürre getroffen
werden.
Denn durstige und gestresste Bäume sind anfällig
für Plagen wie etwa den Borkenkäfer, der
sich bei Wärme und Trockenheit besonders
wohl fühlt.
Schon jetzt führt die Trockenheit dazu, dass
die Gefahr von Waldbränden hoch ist - vor
allem in den östlichen Regionen von Deutschland.
Ob wir 2019 um einen weiteren Dürre-Sommer
drum herum kommen, steht noch in den Sternen.
Dies hängt einzig und allein davon ab, ob
die momentane Trockenheit weiter anhält.
Doch ob dies der Fall sein wird, kann keine
Wetterprognose dieser Welt vorhersagen.
Wenn es von Juni bis August dagegen ohne Ende
regnet, werden wir uns keine Sorgen über
Dürre machen müssen.
Dann wohl eher über Hochwasser.
Doch auszuschließen ist eine anstehende Trockenheit
keinesfalls, denn schließlich wird genau
das vom Klimawandel begünstigt.
Und so steht bereits jetzt fest, dass die
Probleme mit Trockenheit und Dürre in der
Zukunft keineswegs kleiner werden - im Gegenteil.
Der Niederschlag-Zyklus in Mitteleuropa verschiebt
sich schon seit Jahren hin immer mehr ins
Extreme: Im Winter haben die Regenmengen demnach
um rund 10 Prozent zugenommen; deutlich trockener
dagegen präsentieren sich die Sommermonate.
Regionale Klimamodelle bestätigen das und
prognostizieren für Deutschland eine höhere
Wahrscheinlichkeit für längere Trockenphasen.
Der Klimawandel lässt grüßen.
Dazu Sergiy Moroz, ein Sprecher der Nichtregierungsorganisation
“European Environmental Bureau”: “Die
Häufigkeit und Intensität von Dürren wird
aufgrund des Klimawandels zunehmen”.
Auf dasselbe Ergebnis kam auch ein Forschungsteam
vom Helmholtz Zentrum für Umweltforschung
(UFZ) im vergangenen Jahr.
Dazu heißt es auf der Website: “Die globale
Klimaerwärmung wird das Problem der Dürren
in Europa verschärfen - Dürren werden länger
dauern, mehr Flächen und damit mehr Menschen
betreffen.
Erwärmt sich die Erde um drei Grad Celsius,
werden Extremereignisse wie die Dürre im
Jahr 2003 künftig in weiten Teilen Europas
der Normalzustand sein.”
Eine der großen Fragen lautet dann, wie es
mit der Landwirtschaft weitergehen soll.
Denn für die Bewässerung ihrer Felder nutzen
die Bauern Grundwasser.
Doch wenn die Wasserspeicher im Boden nicht
durch Regen aufgefüllt werden, gehen auch
diese Reserven irgendwann zur neige.
Doch wir können dem ganzen Horror-Szenario
entgegen wirken - das betonen auch die Fachleute
vom UFZ: “Die Auswirkungen der globalen
Erwärmung können teilweise mit technischen
Anpassungen gemindert werden.
Diese sind jedoch kostspielig”.
Gemeint ist damit die konsequente Umsetzung
der Klimaschutzziele des Pariser Abkommens.
Sprich: Ausbau des Bahnverkehrs, weniger Individualverkehr,
Kohleausstieg, Energieerzeugung mit regenerativen
Energien, Elektromobilität undsoweiter uuuuund
gaaaanz wichtig Denn auch wir können ganz
konkret etwas tun: Wir können am 26.
Mai zur Europawahl gehen und genau die Partei
wählen, die die Standpunkte vertritt, die
jetzt wichtig sind und unser Überleben sichern.
Wir sind diejenigen, die entscheiden!
Also laßt es uns tun!
Hashtag #diesmalwahleich Mehr dazu im Video
von phoenix EU-Wahl: So funktioniert die Europawahl
am 26.
Mai 2019 anklicken, anschauen und zur Wahl
gehen würde ich mal sagen!
Wir sehen uns am 26.
Mai im Wahllokal.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!